Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to The Escapists 2
Now, it's been a long time since I played The Escapists and if you remember I wasn't any sort of good at it
But now it's the sequel in Beta and this is a very early access build of it by the way
But now that it's in Beta. I'm gonna try to be ruuu- there's vs. holy shit. There's leADERBOARDs holy shit
There's a criminal record! "My Characters". *markimoo gasp* Yesssss
My God I get to make characters. I'm gonna name you Bumbo. Oh, you're gonna have a- that face
You're gonna have a-this color you're Gonna have a
o Bumbo Bumbo Bumbo
*noise*BUMBO! Oh, I just realized I'm making Bumbo myself.. Bumbo with this smile of gold- is that even a smile?
Dohh! there he is I guess you're not Bumbo anymore y-you're mark, you're Markumbo.
woo mark-Markumbo is a bad name. Markumbo ain't the name you'd normally want to go with when you're making a character.
But uh- you know what it is. It is what it izz.
Welp, we're off to a great start with Markumbo over there.
Alright, well how about Frumpton? You're Frumpton. All right cool *grunt*, hell ya Frumpton. Oh yea get it it Frumpton.
Oh Frumpy, oh Frumpton, oh Frumpton my man! I liked it better when you were before Frumpton.
Oh Frumpton, oh Frumpton! Oh hell yeah Frumpton! Alright your gonna be aaaaab(z)?
I'd like to think that the name is inspired by the character that I make, and this guy is not Assbackwards this guy is-
*breaking up in laughter* Plumpleton
do he have that plump ass hE DO- (please forgive me)
HEY! Hey Plumpleton! Heyyy, Plumpleton! How you doin (im doing just fine i lied im dieing on the inside) I like to end my names in "tons"!
You know what I'm saying? all right. let me make the face first. I- a- oh thats good.
This is *laughing* this is Uncle Cunkle.  This is Uncle *more laughing* Cunkle.
Everybody say hi to Uncle Cunkle there! (Hi, Uncle Cunkle!)
aaaaa-
got-
sssssss- Sterbleffffloo.
This is Sterblfloo. I like it Sterblofloo, you're good. This is *even more laughter* cag- caggle- cagglemeister.
*EXTREME LAUGHING* cagglem- caggleme- God dammit. cagglemumfler. that's cagglemumfler.
This is Grillery.
your, ur cr-crunklebutt. (and) wa *starts laughing AGAIN* msley
and- uh- (a pet named) steve.
so we got Markumbo, Frumpton, Plumpleton, Uncle Cunkle, Sterblefloo, cagglemumflr, Grillery. Crunclebutt, Wamsley, and Steve.
and that's my team! God that took way too long- uuuhhh that was too fun.
Alright, so, again, I'm not a hundred percent good at this game because I'm not patient but
I'm going to go at this with the most intelligence that I can possibly go through and hope for the best!
ooh online prison? *markigasp* *high pitched* online prisoners?
ohhh- Refresh with the basics? aaa who needs to do that?
I certainly do not. I need to introduce myself with everybody heeere. new game. That's so cool. You can play with other people!
Oh! That's awesome!
Center Perks 2.0 is the first proper prison. However the guards won't let you have everything your own way. this  is a challenging game.
Follow the yellow arrow to attend routines and keep a low profile. Explore the prison well, keep a lookout for any
weaknesses find the materials you need to craft the tools for your escape!
Try and keep your heat and security level low to avoid trouble from the guards.
The most straightforward way of escape because breaking through the Prison's border.
For example, you might tunnel, chip or cut your way out. Good luck!
Where's my guys, where's my guys? Well- where's my guys??
Hey
Hey, come on now. Where- my guys? Oh? Where's- I juz-
Uh Chomps. Feefs? Staszek IGRAszek
*marki getting frustrated* Uh where's my guys?
I didn't just spend all that time making my guys just for you to toss them out to the wind like that!
Alright FINE. Wow, these guys all look sad.
I think I'll go with this one everyone seems to looks at and downtrodden except for these few guys here.
Oh, they woke up. Oh look at them.  I don't care. (Mark thats rude)
All right, let's go into to this don't know where Markcumbo went but *face*
Where's Frumpleton. Gah. Where's Grillery? Where's Steve? *high pitched* Oh there? There's my guys oh
Markcumbo,
Frumpleton,
Plumpleton, Uncle Cunkle, Sterblefloo, cagglemumflr, Grillery. Welp that one doesn't exist apparently.
Wamsley, Steve, what's wrong with this one?
Bullshit. All right Markumbo. Get in here Markumbo. what you do?
"Welcome to Central Perks 2.0. Your reform starts here." All right cool great
What did I do? "Roll call is mandatory" greeaat "The prison will lock down if you are not present."
"The food served in our canteen is a great source of health and energy." Great.
Cool.
"Escape attempts will be reported to our control room." Great. Okay alright, then.
"Increase your intelligence by reading our books"
Great. I like that. That sounds good.
Thanks for the tour by the way.
[I] like it.
"And use the gym equipment to increase your strength and speed." That dos- You say that that way that that way it doesn-
"Earn some money by visiting our job *brooklyn accent* officers. *regular voice* officers." Alright cool.
"We will allocate one of these rooms for you to stay in."
Alright! Sweet digs.
This is some pretty nice dugs. "As you can see, we have a film crew with us for a while."
"Please don't interrupt their filming." I would never!
*soffs*I would never 'Hello everybody my name is Markiplier' out there.
Ah. "BumBum has joined the game" That's so cool! You can play multiplayer with people!
*markinoise* Lilililililili Hey, wake up. Hey, ASSHOLE.
ASSHOLE! WAIT- Okay, there we go, Yep!
Alright hello. I'm here Linds and Pop.
Oh boy. Random searches this seems fair. Markumple- Markcumbo don't like this.
Markumbo ain't too happy about this.
Euw. Oh. Wow!
Excuse you
Why are you guys so rude? you're do- oh jeez hey, how's it going there Bubba?
Jeez.
Ye.
This place is brutal...
More brutal than I remember it being.
hMM. I was showing off my mug when someone blindsided me. No idea where it could of landed. If you see it let me know.
What? Ooh. I dont know what that "Find Mandzio's mug."
Okay, paper good. That sounds good. Tea bag, sock, duct tape yep. Okay mug. I found A mug
I didn't find THE mug. *skip* Didly dee. Didly dee.
Uh oh. Guard in-coming guard in-coming! Ooh boy. I'm not in here. I'm not in here. You didn't see anything!
*song* Alright anybody else got some good stuff around here? Anybody else got some good stuff? Hey?
Yeah, good stuff that I can stuff in my po-
Whoo-hoo, hey that's contraband, but I like it.
Alright alright alright. Okay?
Okay. What else we got here? Oooh screwdriver?
Bottle of aft-o-shave. Oh box. Is that Tiny Box Tim?
Yeah, better- that guys probably gonna come up to this way bECAUSE I GOT A NAIL FILE ON Me!
And I don't want to lose you. Woooo heyyy- We get those in there. I think those are contraband,
So those got to be hidden away nice and safe like. Alright. Got some goodies. Got some goodies in here wait
Was this THE mug? OOhhh.
Well, that's the mug. Oh, where do I bring that to oh?
Okay, alright alright. Man. There's a lot of free time they give us. Hey, Mandzio!
M- M- M-M- Oh, he's up stairs. Where is there even a upstairs around here?
Okay, anyday now. uh okay. Thank you. Uh oh, Mandzio's about to come down.
Mandzio? Mandzio? Mandzio, buddy. Hey, I got money! And- and
reputation! Okay, Well Mandzio,
Mandzio, uhhh, Mandzio.
This is sad. I don't need to eat. So I guess I'm fine, but let's see what everybody else wants. Hey Healy!
"Constant pest" ah
Naw I'm okay. Don't want to beat anybody up. "Plant this wall block in their desk and I'll anonymously tip them off." Ooooh!
All right, okay, all right.
Mmmm, interesting.
Well, I'm just gonna go off and plant a brick in somebody's desk.
I hope nobody minds. Hello, Sir, Markumbo on the way! Nobody mind Markumbo.
Markumbo don't mind you  so don't mind Markumbo. We're- a job time? Well. I don't have a job
I don't have a job at all okay. All right. Let's see put this in there.
Oh no, oh , I don't even need- WOAH WHY DO I HAVE THAT OUT in the open? Huh? How do I get it out?
Oh, God, I didn't want to put the- oh shit ah fuck fuck a duck ah shit, okay. We're fine. Everything's good.
Hey officers. I'm not dawdling. What are you dawdling about? Hey, Daaadly Man. How you doin, Dawdle boys?
Who'd be- doubt you think I'd be dawdling
Do you know me you know how I dawdle?  You know my dawdling ways, days are over. "Get moving!"
But I don't know where- where would I'm- Oh, I need to move over theerre. Okay. Whoops sorry. Sorry guys. Sorry. Sorry
Sorry, sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I'm moving. I'm moving. I'm moving. I am moving. (Yee x4)
Diddly Dee, Diddly dee.
Alright, I'll find a job. *markinhale* Aaaaa.
"You have to attend the job office when you don't have a job. Speaking to the job office staff will reward you with money."
This is awkward. S- Why?
You're just an idiot, that was my one what?
*squeaks*Oookay.
Thank you?
Thank you for that. I feel so good. *skip* All right. What's up next? Oof
Exercise time? Hell yeah, all right,--ooohEY PUPPIES! Poochie's
Poochers! Look at the the Poochers out there Oh, that's good though.
Well good to know. Roughing it. Oh ah.
Got it. What? Oh that's so cool. (SO COOOOL) Oh look at me! Oh look at me!
Oh, look at me. I'm so tired! Oh no. I'm too tired. Okay. Goodbye! Alright, well that's interesting. I'll shower up before everybody else. Ah.
That's a good stuff. I'm not quite naked, but you know it's th- the thought that counts. Oh wait-
I'M ALREADY SHOWERING YOU FOOLS!
Oh you thought you got me, but you didn't haaaa. Yeah, you don't got me you never got me all right excuse me officer.
I don't know whose desk this is. Gabe's? Oh, okay, alright.don't know. All right...
Uuuuh, Nah, dont need any of that.
Probably need some of that. I don't even know what i need any anymore.
I don't have any crafting skills, Diddly doo, half-shaved sheet of metal? Fuck. Yeah, take that all right. I'm pretty full up
I gotta go back and dump some contraband because I am
walking in trouble! *skipppppy*Ooo what could I maaake?
Poster, manicure kit, that's good. Ooooh, I need more stuff.
Alright, but I need to learn. I need to learn a thing or two. Where do I go to learn that's what I was looking for.
It was upstairs somewhere wasn't it? Where to learn? This place here? Did you teach me something? Who are you? Hillary?
What are you doing here? Teach me. I want to learn I'm here to learn.  What is this solitary?
What is this that's some good stuff, but I don't think I got a room for that until I got more...
Till I know what I'm going for, I just need to learn. "I could be your friend, please?" No thank you.
I don't want that. That sound awful. Oh.
Oh, I needed to be at dinner time oopsies, oopsies poopsie. Huh, what the hell is this? Ah.
I see oh, oh
Intelligence is flowing through me. I'm so smart now!
Look, how smart my big brain is! How they think this is difficult?
They didn't go to Harvard like I did. Harvard Penitentiary! Ha, ha, ha, ha!
A ha ha!
I am very tired.
Nope too tired!
I got a shower so I can get all not tired and such. Such as the like as that. Can I get a shower?
Imma shower up don't mind me. He's like this yeah, all right. Scuse me! I got to say I really like this!
It's a bit of an improvement over what was before- Woo that is some good shit, but I don't have the money for it right now.
This the good stuff.
I'm gonna be so smart! Oh.
So smart right now. You guys jealous about how smart I am? Oh look at me. God! I'm so brilliant my brains-
Markumbo ain't never seen nobody no smarter than Markumbo is what I'm trying to say. God.
Ooh, too tired, ah piss and vinegar.
I could really do a rest. Can I go take a nap? Can I take a nap?
Is that something I can do? Can I just lights out already? I've had enough of this bullshit. waIT. THIS IS NOT MY BED!
Eug, sorry excuse me. Sorry, thought that was my bed, sorry.
Very comfortable tho. Okay, so there's the vent system...
(which is interesting) Alright, just need three more points, and then I'm up to sixty which is pretty much all
I really need, right? They made it a lot easier to learn stuff,
Which is kind of nice that way you're not spending days and day's just eating your brain out trying to learn- Roll call!
I'm ready for roll call. I'm so ready for that. Hey you want to give me whatever quest you talking about over there?
Hey, what are you going on for me? NO I didn't want to sit I wanted to talk to my buddy here! My buddy Chancer.
[let's] see.
No, I don't want- A medic outfit? No.
I don't want to get your medic oufit. boobity boop boo boo boo boo boo boobi boobi boobity boo boo boo
Mylo... Weapons?
I could probably-
Locate makeshift SPEAR?
Makeshift SPEAR??
Holy shit, that's a that's a doozer. I'm getting a lot of lower reputation just by turning everybody down.
I just don't think I can get these things. I'm returning to my cell~ Don't mind me. I'm sorry. I'm sorry!
*noises* Im just sleeping- sleeping it up!
So anyway! That is The Escapists 2!
There is a lot more to this game that i wanna play, and it's really cool the improvements that they've made.
[Crazy La Paint starts playing in the background, slowly getting louder]
I think I'm going to play a few more episodes of this and then escape this prison.
So thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video! Buh-Bye!
[Crazy La Paint playing full volume]
(if you see this comment "Rose")
(Bye have a good time~)